if you're 22 18 25 30 and you think you
should have your whole life figured out
that's ludicrous I genuinely believe the
world is telling you the reverse of the
right information when you're this young
the number one thing you should do is
the most high risk behavior of your life
this is exactly when you should go live
in Bali for a year this is exactly when
you try to become Beyonce this is
exactly when you do the highest risk the
biggest thing I want for everybody in
this room is to do random go put
out a song taste in your 20s you
got a taste it's no different than
kissing a bunch of frogs until you find
your prince the people that will cast
judgment on someone who's still trying
to explore are people who themselves
settled without exploring parents these
are your best friends these are your
siblings they're not intending to be
mean tear you down stop you conform you
into settling like they did but that's
exactly what they're doing Society is
incredibly subconsciously interested in
you conforming don't